la France n'a jamais été indépendante
énergétiquement depuis qu'elle a quitté
l'air des énergies renouvelables
c'est-à-dire que nous étions indépendant
énergétiquement à l'époque où nous
utilisions exclusivement les pierres et
le bois du sol français pour construire
des moulins à vent les pierres du sol
français pour construire des moulins à
eau et le bois français et l'herbe
française pour faire avancer des animaux
de traits depuis que nous sommes rentrés
dans l'ère des combustibles fossiles et
de l'énergie nucléaire et des nouvelles
énergies renouvelables etc en fait nous
ne sommes pas indépendants parce que
nous dépend d'une espèce d'imbrication
des énergies je sais pas si l'historien
des énergies qui est venue ici c'est
Jean-Baptiste fresoses non c'est pas lui
mais sinon en fait il y a une
imbrication des énergies qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dégager
une énergie de façon individualisée d'un
système elles sont toutes imbriquées et
par exemple on ne fait pas de réacteur
nucléaire sans métallurgie donc sans
charbon on ne fait pas de panneaux
photovoltaïques sans électricité au
charbon donc sans charbon on ne fait pas
on ne fait pas venir depuis la Chine
sans pétrole parce que il faut que ça
vienne donc en fait il y a une
implication d'énergie aujourd'hui et
sauf à ce qu'un pays maîtrise sur son
sol la totalité à la fois des sources
énergétiques impliquées donc la totalité
des énergies actuellement utilisées dans
le monde et la totalité des mines
métalliques qui sont nécessaires pour
fournir les dispositifs d'extraction de
l'énergie de l'environnement et de
transformation en des vecteurs
énergétiques qui permettent d'alimenter
nos machines et bien on ne peut pas
parler d'indépendance énergétique ou de
souveraineté énergétique donc en fait
aucun pays ne la possède totalement
l'Arabie saoudite a plus de pétrole que
nous mais elle a pas de mine de fer donc
si elle était à frontière fermée sans
aucune communication avec l'extérieur
elle ne pourrait pas exploiter son
pétrole voilà donc c'était juste un
petit une petite remarque préliminaire
pour dire que les mots ayant un sens
enfin en tout cas j'imagine qu'ils en
ont un dans la Commission dans le titre
de la commission d'enquête
je voulais juste faire remarquer que
l'indépendance ça n'existe pas stricte
au sang et que la bonne question pour
moi me semble être pour l'ensemble du
système énergétique de savoir de qui on
dépend
dans quelle proportion avec quelle
aptitude à se retourner si jamais on a
un problème avec les gens dont on dépend
voilà c'est ça les bonnes questions et
donc c'est des questions qui sont
nécessairement quantifiées et calendez
avoir un débat c'est pas du tout
agressif ce que je veux dire mais avoir
un débat philosophique sur
l'indépendance en fait c'est très
intéressant le soir passé 23 heures mais
sinon dans l'absolu ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pratique
et je vais finir ce petit exposé
luminaire en rappelant que la France
quand on regarde ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie finale c'est-à-dire l'énergie
qui alimente les machines qui nous
rendent la vie si douce qu'il s'agisse
des ascenseurs des tractopelles des
trains ou des laminoirs l'essentiel de
l'énergie qui rentre dans une machine en
France qui nous rend un service quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit de la mobilité
de etc c'est des combustible fossiles et
que la France sauf erreur de ma part ne
possède plus du tout de Gilles vend de
gaz sur son sol et possède 1% enfin
extra extrait de l'environnement 1% du
pétrole qu'elle consomme
je vais également faire un petit rappel
j'avais dans alors pas dans l'hémicycle
ni dans cette salle mais dans une autre
salle de l'Assemblée il y a très très
longtemps participé à un colloque
organisé par Yves Cochet qui avait fait
rigoler tout le monde à l'époque sur le
pic de production du pétrole ça devait
être une quinzaine d'années je crois
je voudrais rappeler que le pic de
production du pétrole depuis est passé
en ce qui concerne le pétrole
conventionnel c'est-à-dire que tout ce
qui n'est pas le shaila et l'américain
et les sables bitumineux Canadiens est
passé par un maximum en 2008 dans le
monde il y a un lien direct avec la ce
qu'on a appelé la crise des subprimes
que depuis ça décline et que en ce qui
concerne l'Europe l'Europe est en
approvisionnement contraint à la baisse
sur son pétrole depuis cette date
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
géologique d'accord que ça nous plaise
ou que ça nous plaise pas ça va
s'accélérer dans les décennies qui
viennent et en particulier il y a un
travail très complet qui a été fait par
le chiffre projet qui est public qui est
disponible sur notre site qui porte sur
les possibilités de production de
pétrole sous sol contraintes géologique
des 16 premiers fournisseurs de l'Europe
qui sont par ailleurs les 16 premiers
producteurs mondiaux hors-brésil et
Canada et la conclusion de ce travail
qui a été menée par deux anciens cadres
dirigeants total et pas n'importe
lesquels puisqu'il s'agissait de la
personne qui était en charge de
l'évaluation des gisements et la
l'exploration c'est que la production de
nos 16 premiers fournisseurs devraient
divisés par 2 d'ici à 2050 ce qui veut
dire que leurs exportations vers
l'Europe vont être divisés par n'importe
quoi entre 2 et 20
donc de la perte de souveraineté sur le
pétrole faut s'attendre à en avoir et
pas qu'un peu en ce qui concerne le gaz
le Shipp project va publier en novembre
dans quelques jours là un travail
similaire qu'on a fait sur le gaz confié
à des personnes de même tabac avec des
données qui sont en qui sont issues du
même endroit c'est-à-dire une base de
données de l'ensemble des gisements de
pétrole et de gaz dans le monde qu'elle
on a laquelle on a eu accès
et le résultat de ce travail c'est que
le pic de production pour le gaz dans le
monde dans son ensemble c'est 2030 celui
pour la mer du Nord c'était 2005 donc si
on ajoute à ça le fait que le charbon
est en déplétion géologique en Europe
depuis 1950 enfin depuis les années 50
en gros en fait sur toutes les énergies
fossiles l'Europe étant entre guillemets
perte de souveraineté
depuis
2005 pour le gaz
2008 pour le pétrole et les années 50
pour le charbon avant même qu'il y ait
des sujets de climat voilà c'est dans ce
donc il faut bien voir que en fait sur
les énergies fossiles qui sont le
premier moteur de la civilisation dans
lequel nous vivons la question de la
perte de souveraineté elle est déjà à
l'oeuvre depuis longtemps et ça va
s'accélérer et ça va se traduire
directement en contraction de flux de
toute nature que l'on a l'habitude de
résumer classiquement sous l'angle PIB
mais voilà on va avoir un sujet de
contraction des flux de toute façon on
en est en vie ou pas